you have to pay every time somebody o
what R me babyk get get in Mark get in
oh what do you what what what wait wait
wait did you not just see the thing that
was over there how how did
youy oh what Freddy help help help get
in
here Freddy Freddy Freddy we got a
Freddy I'm going out the fire exit yeah
screw that screw
that Mark put out the bad fire
what oh my God oh my God that no I
know w
w oh oh oh CRA wo wo kill him can we
kill kill ow ow do we
[Music]
kill we we I like that I like that
answer actually for you you can read it
put it on the computer all right cool
we'll go in the fire exit that we can
trust yeah well we can try uh AR stay
outside for a minute okay we just want
to catch our breath you know all times
but seriously you just hit me with the
shovel cuz you almost killed me but just
now or when the creature was whenever
the creature popped up someone hit me
with the shovel I'm I don't want to
point any fingers at who might have hit
you look I I'm willing to admit that it
might have been Wade he's always he's
always swing sh over okay all right I'm
just saying a gun it was G you gun damn
you I'll shovel you
God God I'm sure it's safe by
now I'm I'm going to go in this door
over
here I'm going Clan away like a
baby you'll heal
up I don't like this yeah goodbye
friends it's not meant to be
liked
oh I found Ryan what do you
mean
uh I don't know what that
means
man there's so much nothing here oh got
a big bolt that's what I got all
right well this is a dead end where do
we go
whoa hey there you are do you have a
locky oh I do yeah why oh it's must be
powered
off I found Mark he's sorry my walkie
was powered off uh yeah sorry is this
it's all just one really long dead end
yeah it goes nowhere oh there's areas
you just got to find the
AA can I wait yeah is there an offshoot
that we don't know about oh all the way
back I see I see I see I
see well I do know this
area is this a door oh hey there's a
pretty bracking fast boy should we kill
it we can
try
there's not many places to like maneuver
here no no it's it's really uh kind of
crammed oh hey guys I found the comedy
mask y don't don't put it on what was
that put it on
over the bug thing is that the crawler
you see the dog also I
think the theing bug the warning bug is
not the
crawler I'm fighting for my life against
the
crawler wait I have a picture of Ryan
Reynold I'm fully looted up
here the crab oh
my good god oh there we go that's not a
crawler I hate to tell you but we did
kill it damn it B needs help
down I
I'm Oh I thought this was I got
confused I'm I'm here I'm up I went up
the little side stairway I'm coming down
hello you need help carry stuff I'm I'm
full up but I um I don't have anything
extra right now but I just have my hands
full I got two
slots there is still a Freddy Bracken
bear somewhere down here he is yeah that
what do we do about that don't stare
don't stare at him don't stare at him
okay don't stare at him should we go at
him but not stare at him okay should we
just get out of here then we want to go
we want to go out to the right and close
the
door yep that's
fine oh that sounds ter he's Chu he he's
chuckling he's chuckling he's
chuckling
bad Chuckles keep closing the doors yeah
yeah this is standard SCP
procedure no dead bug hey look out it's
the bo
b where's the um exit area over here I
think it's around this corner yeah it's
over
here right here definitely real 100%
real
exit oh okay oh God it is so he let's
get out of here I want want to go
home hope we have enough stuff yeah we
probably got enough Qui quiet quiet you
go to the
ship I got to rejoin I'll be right
P got
it
yeah Mar are you ready no but okay 3 2
1 hey man
hi I didn't know you could jump to the
ship he didn't tell me that no no no if
you so there is lethal fall damage you
can only jump so far he must have like
hit the rail and then gone down from the
rail if he jumped from there to the ship
he I think he'd be dead well we got to
hope that this is
enough what was our quota like 500
something yeah pretty high this SCP
place is rough man yeah yeah I wonder uh
who kept coming here that was weird well
no by default this is the normal map
that's a mod that gives a random chance
of any map being the scvp map I think ah
normally this is the factory map like
the normal moons the Mansion map layout
is usually when we go down now we made
enough
money I say it to everybody and we're
all good oh there's nothing to worry
about oh hey hey all right I think this
is the worst haul we've ever had from I
Didn't Know Bob I didn't know you could
jump to the ship I jumped towards way
stuff so you jump down to where the dog
was and then it just ate you yeah you
said are you ready and I'm like I guess
well I don't know what the plan is like
I'm not as telepathic as you I thought
the plan was obvious get the hell out of
there I wanted to all right let's see
what we you should have done you should
have followed your
guts all right well maybe the company
will be very forgiving almost definitely
yeah wait if you just shake like that in
front of the
window all will be well I can do
that oh we got some good stuff we got
some stuff yeah we got some DEC L good
stuff yeah yeah I'm glad you guys picked
up the stuff every time I died but it's
not
impossible where's my do it this might
do
it uh too bad the keys aren't worth
anything like five no this will do it we
got this we got this
this yeah yeah let's hang on I'll join
you I'll join you give my show give my
show well hang on wa trying
to yeah oh what do you think of that
company H yeah oh give us lots of money
like $700
worth oh oh that's close that's close is
that what we two things yeah yeah
yeah oh
oh hang on hang on wait wait wait hang
on hang on hang on there's two more
items for sale all right okay okay
oh hey we get we did
it just all these keys I was holding for
no particular reason I can't believe
that we did that yeah that was I didn't
think we brought anything back well I
didn't I definitely didn't bring
anything back those were some rough runs
yeah yeah not great not our best but hey
we'll get it together uh and this next
time we're going to we're going to nail
it what's the point of this teleporters
I don't think it's very useful I mean
one brings your body back or saves your
life if you're you know in Peril and you
have a walk you're like save me save me
save me you have who are competent yeah
the other one if you go to a moon has
like eclipsed or flooded or something
really bad you can teleport in that way
you don't have to get through the Perils
of the outside but that's a
big whoa hey watch out there it's making
things a little bit more streamlined
yeah that's good that's good that's good
wait is this we got our overtime bonus
already I think so I don't know so how
we're swimming in it right we got
options um swimming in it which which
moon did you like better between the the
paid ones did you like the snowy one or
the one with the big Railways I we don't
have to go to the paid one right they
seem bad that's where all the good stuff
is though isn't it I don't remember it
didn't seem any better than the it
didn't seem any better than the other
places if we're going to be perfectly
honest we'll try a new one there's
another new one all right I bought
flashlights and walkies but we are now
pretty broke
why are we try to um care making so much
money a lot we've been making quite a
lot of money it's impressive that we're
so it's almost like there's some
embezzling going on it's getting
real yes uh sorry there's nothing
happening you can ring my
bell uh ring my
bell oh good this
place um fascinating W sorry sorry that
was honestly an
[Music]
accident oh I got a sign to get a whoopy
cushion oh those are cool I like whoopy
cushions yeah I know all right all right
this time I'm turning on my radio I'll
take you that all right going for it
let's do this boys I'm going to I'm
going to be the man in the man in the
can how's it
going uh don't call me that
I thought what you called yourself ship
you got
this uh yeah I got this yeah I'll get
i'll get a whoopy
cushion there's that weird interference
happening again on the radio every time
Bob's in the
can I it wouldn't me not do that I
didn't do that to me under the stairs
there's some loots
Chris your and then yeah right there
also behind
you
M there there yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes all right I got gift o nope I
don't like
that I don't like
this Bob is this a real
door uh you standing next to a fire exit
yeah no I don't think that's a real one
I'm going to just out there I think that
might be a fake hey I got a turret issue
keep going the direction you're going
and try to go coming coming to
help I got you
bro thank you yeah those only disabled
for like a moment so it's going to be
back online if you go back through there
Roger
that there are two pieces of loot there
one and another one oh yeah uh who you
talking
to you all right
well honestly I don't know why your
complete lack of support made me laugh
but it did I want you to know
that the turet mark turet turet
Market yeah I know I'm peeking
it wa wait do you want to be teleported
or what n he seems fine I just want you
to know that he's
fine the Christmas spirit is coming to
greet
us I don't know what that means does
that even mean I'm taking some stuff
back to the
ship oh that's fast wait whatever that
is I don't like how fast it moves I see
what it
is uh wait you good
he got
out Mark when you're carrying the mask
in on the first person camera it looks
really good you should come look at the
screen when you
get oh whoa where am I whoa whoa whoa I
got lost that's not the way I got lost I
got lost I was following someone else
who was not who was I
following I'm right here on the light no
but I mean someone else was walking in
front of me out there wait you think
those one dude's are out again I don't
know but
someone I
was bring a link dick Bob did you see
anything on the on the monitor when I
was walking back I I feel like there was
why does that not give any value wait
guys someone go someone leave the ship
and walk straight away from the door
opening I will in one second I'm buying
uh a way to get in the fire exit no no
wait go to your go to your right uh okay
yeah one sec what oh
okay what's up uh yeah go turn right 90°
B I can't hear
you go back stop there now walk that way
forward forward forward forward forward
forward forward little tickle of
right forward forward straight
forward there's loot here question mark
keep going keep going past the
tree wait wait wait wait this L you okay
all right wow that was close I guess we
have to leave is that a tree it is a
tree yeah we leave I got this so we can
take the fire exit tomorrow oh cool damn
it what do you mean damn it what do you
mean damn it I mean I don't want to
leave yet we got four items what the we
we're alive I know we're doing great in
terms of being alive what is with this m
i me that's true don't don't play with
the mask Mark well I mean it didn't give
me any money it didn't say like any
money I'm pretty sure it has a value to
sell I'm fairly
certain says it's worth 64 all right so
uh we're we're doing good hey perfect
weather we're going right back all right
well that's good by the way perfect
weather is what we had last time too
it's still going to be snowy and awful
oh okay all right okay do you see never
mind it's over but if you follow me I
can show show you where the fire exit
is mar I feel like in the fog your
flashlight is way worse than it is
helpful yeah you're right you're right
wa
waa
yeah Wade knows the secrets that's
awesome what that's so cool uh-huh
careful I hear mine somewhere I was in
your
hey there's a turret over here oh good
so that's
fun oh cool oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's bad okay I'll bait it I'll bait
it this way you guys go the other way
around it okay as soon as it's active I
think it turns on a
dime all right here we go here we go
it's going to look at me any minute now
any why are you on this side why are you
on this side walk the other way I'm just
going to go I'm just going to go around
where look at me look at
me look at me look at me look at
me you're welcome guys you're welcome
look at me no no not that way look at me
no look at me look at me look at me he
chose
me it chose me all right
good oh okay all right look go go W Mark
wait till I say and then go
no not like
that look see oh I froze oh no bad time
to freeze oh no oh no oh no oh no
no what uh my game crashed yeah we can
get you back we just have to go to um
orbit that's all good it froze right in
front of L of sight of the turret yeah
so the turret just started shooting and
didn't stop until your body disappeared
so you were just standing there taking
bullets like a [__]
Terminator and Bob and I were just
confused as
[__] yeah that was pretty
good the Moon is
flooded what does that mean is that good
I think that means if we go in we have
to use the fire exit I think the main
entrance is like going to be drown in
water well can we swim no you can't swim
well then how are we going to carry
anything back well I think think it'll
be clear enough at least for the first
part of the day to get to the fire exit
and back and we have the ladder so hey
let me see this what's going on with
these moons well vows not flooded we
paid to be here don't leave oh all right
whatever paid a lot of100 to get here
why' you spend that's why we're broke
why are you spending 500 bucks to get to
a moon because typically if we don't
suck you get a lot more money from these
moons than the normal ones well you
hav't help had a terrible run of luck
well yes that's it that's it everyone
pick a picture picture pick picture
everyone select an image of Ryan
Reynolds to stare at and it'll make you
feel better I want this one all right
I'll take this
one ah all right so we got we got a can
of soda some chattering teeth two hair
dryers and a old telephone and a
mask right yeah I get you guys know I
don't I don't get it turn tables at a
microphone how how it be flooded on a
snow Planet turn table a
microphone how to freaking
hell does it be flooded there it is
here all we're going to be economical
we're going to be strategic we're going
to be good we're going to get them we
need 800 bucks and we got this yes I
Believe in Us I also Believe in a Thing
Called
Love I'm going up the stairs good luck
boys see you soon found the breaker uh
based on what I found I'm also going up
the stairs stairs is the only way to go
yes me too all right stairs it is I hear
a m can we turn the lights on no that's
not all right yeah it didn't work oh
wait key key over here lock
door key key key key ke I don't have I'm
I'm trying to
communicate you had a key in your hand
you have a key in your hand think he's
lying I see a key in your wait you I
give give me your key give me that key
it's in your hand I see it I see the key
in your hand give me your key I don't I
can go get a key from the ship no you
got glowing no you got a key in your
hand I see it don't try to run away you
got that key in your head I see it I'm
not a liar you hear something terrible
what
oh oh God be right back what does he
what do you mean be right
back what do you mean what do you mean
are you still mocking me on the
precipice of death you would mock me at
this moment I'm I'm I'm mocking the lady
from the mocking J what's that but she
did hot ones Jennifer Lawrence you see
Jennifer Lawrence is H what do you mean
what do you what do you mean I get you I
get you i a mean
what that Mark wait how you what is that
sound I think it's a big large thing I'm
back with the key all right cool good he
he had a key I don't understand what you
saw two in his hand he had a key in his
hand he had a key that sounds terrible
what is happening I'm I'm go over
here all right cool oh something is way
louder is that good that's probably good
you still have a key in your hand I know
you
do oh God oh oh oh oh oh oh no Mark oh
no no no Mark he we we lost our star we
lost our star there was a turret that
don't go down that hallway do not go
down that
hallway wa it seems
fun he's he's actually I know
he
Bob
oh God damn
it oh
God all right it's all on
me star player don't sit on the bench
unless you're ready to
play naed
it great more freaking Brian
Reynolds that's what we need right now
in this moment this juncture hey can you
come in here here
yeah right yeah
right freck frck
[__] oh
yeah I'm
good I'm getting a
key no no no lies lies it's all
lies uh guys can you come help me lies
it's lies it's all
lies okay what
happened
oh no not like
this oh it sounds horrible here oh freak
why right there why' you have
to Oh Oh that's oh okay start time here
we
go all right I'm I'm I can't I can't do
ity toble run of Lu I I don't know how
to do I I'm not going to be I what do I
I'm going Le
Goodbye Oh this is oh I hate life right
now I hate oh guys we should
go yeah thank you ghost of Bob oh no
where am I oh oh wo whoa whoa whoa whoo
whoa whoa whoo whoo whoo whoa where am
I not like this it's right
there oh run
now oh go just go go go start
it
[Music]
oh oh God so um I don't know what you
guys saw but there was a turret on the
other side of a bookshelf that sh us
through a
bookshelf yeah I I was I was like oh I'm
confident there's nothing here and then
it the same thing to me I said I said
that no but I could see I could see with
my eyeballs what was happening so I was
like oh must around the corner something
so no it just ignored the fact that
there was a physical bookshelf there did
you guys not hear the message the
message I've never heard before that was
just playing then oh that's the default
it's Day Zero it's time to go to the
company hopefully a lot I I look man I
there was a blob I got one Brian
Reynolds painting and like I thought I
grabbed that Rubik's Cube but apparently
it wasn't fast enough so wow we probably
have
898 uh bucks worth of Lo a small pile
yeah yeah hey on the bright side we're
back with the company and we love the
company we love love the company I don't
know if the company loves us but that's
okay some relationships are like
that you can keep that if you want
really goes with your eyes no I'll sell
it I'll sell it all right okay okay
better hurry better hurry you know boys
it was it was a good
run three working together yeah we are
shockingly close that's closer than I
would have guessed and one rubish Cube
would have really put us over the edge
it would have it would
have no bom
oh maybe the company will forgive us for
our sacrifice of Bob uhhuh yeah uh yeah
okay all right well if only someone
hadn't blown all of our money on
expensive
moons I can't deal with it oh again it's
me again
really F hey we're
back well uh so uh that's not a good
fraction on the screen as you have not
met the profit quarter your performance
has been deemed below
stand Welcome to our disciplinary
process forgive us guys human settied on
the way out
[Music]